[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 c'est votre émission pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
voici le programme de ce mardi 4 juillet
plus de 200 maires de France reçus à la
mi-journée à l'Elysée Emmanuel Macron
s'entretenait avec les élus des villes
touchées par les émeutes urbaines
déclenchées après la mort du jeune Naël
parmi les Edils présents des yvelinois
dans cette même actualité la Présidente
de la Région Île-de-France Valérie
Pécresse est rendue ce matin à La
Verrière là où deux écoles primaires ont
été touchées par des incendies
volontaires ça se passait la semaine
dernière sur le campus de l'Institut
international de l'image et du son à
Élancourt la première édition des
troisièces days avait pour but de
valoriser et présenter les productions
des étudiants de plusieurs filières qui
recrutent notamment celle du jeu vidéo
ou encore celle du film d'animation
retour avec nos invités
et puis l'émission va démarrer pour une
18e saison sur M6 le casting de La
France a un incroyable talent passer le
week-end dernier par le centre
commercial eau shopping de plaisir entre
chant dans sa Croatie magie ou humour 80
candidats ont tenté leur chance
et puis plusieurs invités en plateau
notamment
Eric Alain Genèse bonsoir bonsoir mère
adjoint de la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous êtes délégué
vous à la citoyenneté à la sécurité et
la commune a été touchée comme bien
d'autres dans les Yvelines par ce
phénomène un violence urbaine depuis une
semaine désormais déclenché par la mort
du jeune nail qui a été tué par un
policier lors d'un contrôle routier à
Nanterre comment c'est déroulé la nuit
dernière est-ce que à l'image de
d'autres villes en France il y a le pic
désormais des violences qui est passé
comme l'affirmé aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron le président de la République oui
on peut dire que le pic est passé la
nuit dernière a été nettement plus calme
que les précédentes et on a eu très très
peu de d'événements déplorés sur la
ville l'occasion de revenir sur les
faits marquants de cette semaine à
Montigny le Bretonneux et je le disais
aussi on va parler des trois isdays dans
cette émission un plus précisément avec
la filière animation aussi qui avait son
événement dédié troisis anime c'était
lors de la journée du 27 juin deux
invités sont avec moi en plateau Sylvain
Bonet et liesse en bas bonsoir tous les
deux alors Sylvain Bonet vous êtes vous
responsable pédagogique de la filière
animation à 3IS l'Institut
internationale de l'image et du son qui
est situé à Élancourt il y a un campus
parisien qui est situé à Élancourt et
vous Ilyes vous êtes étudiant en cinéma
d'animation 2D bah tout simplement quel
était l'objectif de la journée 3e à
Nîmes et ben c'était l'objectif de cette
journée c'était de mettre en valeur
effectivement toutes ces productions qui
ont été réalisées par nos incroyables
étudiants en cette fin d'année donc sur
des films qui sont pour la plupart des
courts-métrages donc catégorie Film
d'Animation et puis également de
production qui sont plutôt des
productions de série d'animation qui
sont portés sur des problématiques
plutôt pour la télévision sur des
systèmes de série voilà donc rencontre
avec des professionnels retour avec les
professionnels et puis diffusion dans
les grandes salles de l'école pour pour
effectivement que tout le monde en
prenne plein les yeux et avoir un petit
défi en cette fin de journée l'occasion
d'y revenir tout à l'heure présenter
aussi cette filière animation vous avez
pu présenter votre production aussi
effectivement c'était
valorisant pour vous de pouvoir la
présenter à un public venu pour ses
portes ouvertes oui c'est très
valorisant et ça permet de d'attaquer un
petit peu le monde professionnel d'une
certaine manière commençait à un peu y
toucher voir les différentes têtes etc
nous allons nous raconter tout à l'heure
un petit peu les coulisses de votre
formation ce que vous avez pu suivre
comme cours cette année à 3IS également
Régine ralech de la rédaction de tv78
bonsoir Régine dans un instant vous
allez nous présenter les informations du
jour à retenir dans les Yvelines pour
cette journée du Mardi 4 juillet ce sera
juste après avoir regardé les prévisions
météo de demain
journée de mercredi similaire à celle
d'aujourd'hui des éclaircies le matin
avec des températures plus fraîches
compter 15 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 13
degrés à Rambouillet et 14 degrés dans
les secteurs de Houdan et Versailles
dans l'après-midi quelques gouttes de
pluie sont attendus fera 20 degrés sur
l'ensemble du territoire yvelinois et
demain mercredi 5 juillet et nous
fêterons les Antoine le point présent
sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
et je le disais dans les titres Régine
plus de 200 mères ont été reçus ce mardi
à l'Élysée tout à fait Grégory est comme
vous le savez ces derniers jours
plusieurs communes de France ont connu
des épisodes de violences certains mères
ont également été victimes d'exaction
alors Emmanuel Macron le chef de l'État
a donc invité les maires de 241 communes
ciblées par des violences ils ont abordé
plusieurs sujets relatifs aux banlieue à
la sécurité ou encore à la politique de
la ville le Président a d'ailleurs
annoncé une loi d'urgence pour accélérer
la reconstruction plusieurs mères des
Yvelines étaient présents dont Joséphine
Coleman's berger maire de plaisir on
l'écoute
[Musique]
le jour était pas à des prises de
décision n'était pas du tout à dire on
va faire si on va faire ça pas du tout
ce qui était important c'est que on
puisse les uns et les autres exprimer
nos inquiétudes notre douleur de ce qui
s'est passé et aussi ce qu'on imagine
pouvoir éventuellement faire donc je
dirais qu'il y a eu une écoute voilà
après ce qu'on a été entendu je ne sais
pas et qu'est-ce qui va se mettre en
place je ne sais pas non plus
[Musique]
alors il y a eu des remarques malgré
tout sur le fait qu'on est supprimé les
polices de proximité on a aussi évoqué
le plan Borlo qui pour nous a été
échangé déplacé enlever il a été évoqué
également très rapidement le fait que il
va falloir peut-être être un tout petit
peu plus attentif à tout ce qui fait
l'éducation des enfants et l'autorité
parentale également le fait que la
justice
puisse avoir les mains un peu plus
libres par rapport à tout ce qui est je
dirais la condamnation éventuelle bien
sûr des mineurs
[Musique]
dans la pandémie c'est quand même les
mères qui étaient au premier front et là
qui sait qui était sur le trottoir dans
les nuits blanches avec dans les
voitures banalisées c'est nous c'est les
élus donc c'est ça qu'on veut faire
comprendre au président est-ce que je
voudrais lui faire comprendre c'est que
quand on a des élus qui ne viennent pas
du terrain qui n'ont pas d'expérience de
terrain comme certains parlementaires
malheureusement et qui ne savent pas ce
que c'est que le quotidien et bien ça
peut pas vraiment bien fonctionner donc
oui merci de nous avoir reçu mais on
existe et heureusement qu'on exit si on
n'existait pas je peux vous dire que la
France elle grille beaucoup plus mal
encore beaucoup plus mal
[Musique]
il y avait aussi Nicolas Dainville le
maire de la verrière qui a reçu ce matin
dans sa ville Valérie Pécresse la prison
de la région Île-de-France tout à fait
vous en souvenez très certainement deux
établissements de la ville ont été
incendiés dans la nuit du 28 au 29 juin
l'école élémentaire du bois de l'étang
et une bonne partie de l'école
maternelle des Noé 170 élèves se sont
donc retrouvés sans école et donc ce
matin Valérie Pécresse s'est rendu sur
place pour visiter une structure qui
accueillera les enfants pour la rentrée
prochaine le reportage de Céline Charles
et de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude des
salles de classe il nous reste plus que
quelques trous sur le sol et des
manteaux qui ne retrouveront jamais
leurs propriétaires une situation qui a
mobilisé les élus locaux quand on
s'attaque aux écoles c'est avec une
volonté très nette très clair très
cynique de s'attaquer à la République
dans les quartiers et d'empêcher les
jeunes des quartiers d'avoir un espoir
la présidente du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France s'est rendue sur la
commune pour c'est la mise à disposition
d'une RPD école régionale du 1er degré
elle accueillera les élèves dès la
rentrée prochaine ils sont 170 à être
concernés ils étaient scolarisés à
l'école élémentaire du bois de l'étang
et l'école maternelle des Noé cible
d'incendie volontaires jeudi 29 juin
nous allons réaliser tous les travaux
d'accueil je tenais à le dire maintenant
avant que les parents ne partent en
vacances parce que j'ai vu des parents
pleurs parce que j'ai vu des enfants qui
étaient très inquiets j'ai l'impression
qu'on se doit de répondre à une demande
qui urgente et puis il y a notre mission
de service public et donc il y avait pas
de question à se poser là derrière est
une commune qui a besoin de continuer à
je dirais à ce que leurs élèves
poursuivent une scolarité dans les
meilleures conditions le RPD pouvait
répondre à cette demande donc il y avait
pas de sujets la région Île-de-France
votera mercredi une aide d'urgence de 20
millions d'euros pour aider les maires à
reconstruire les équipements publics le
Conseil départemental des Yvelines
apportera aussi une aide financière on a
décidé dès maintenant d'un de fond
d'urgence qui sera fait au cas par cas
pour les communes pour les aider à
reconstruire les bâtiments dégradés
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que des
communes des petites communes n'ont pas
les moyens de reconstruire ces
équipements les élèves devraient être
accueillis à l'ERPD pour un minimum de
deux ans de quoi laisser aux écoles le
temps d'être reconstruite
et toujours dans cette actualité des
violences
urbaines Île-de-France mobilité estime à
plus de 20 millions d'euros le coût des
destructions infligées au transport
public que ce soit la circulation des
bus et des tramways est autorisé dans
toute la France jusqu'à 22h au lieu de
21h comme c'était le cas ces derniers
jours actualités du jour heureuse pour
certains malheureux pour d'autres les
résultats du bac ont été révélés ce
matin aujourd'hui mardi 4 juillet
c'était la date fatidique pour des
millions de lycéens des 8 heures les
résultats du baccalauréat étaient
affichés dans les établissements et
disponible également sur internet alors
dans les Yvelines c'est plus de 87% de
réussite dans toutes les séries
confondues contre 89 l'an dernier alors
on est parti à la rencontre de certains
bacheliers au lycée Descartes à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux écouter leurs
réactions
très bien
et globalement bah j'ai un bon ressenti
du coup forcément
donc soulager le bac c'était assez
compliqué mais à force de révision on a
réussi c'est ça le plus important j'ai
appelé tout le monde mes parents mes
grands-parents toute la famille est
content après les épreuves laissaient
vachement tout dans l'année du coup on
pouvait facilement savoir si on l'avait
déjà mais c'est un soulagement d'avoir
au moins une mention autour de ce que
vous avez des souvenirs du jour du
résultat de du bac oui c'était moi
j'étais passé à Versailles au lycée La
Brière et ça c'est faire l'imprimidité
effectivement alors j'ai à peu près mes
résultats et oui ce jour là je vois
qu'on a on a bien fait Seiller après
avec l'après-midi dans les quartiers de
Versailles dans les bars et restaurants
moi c'était l'année du covid juste après
et du coup on a eu les notes en contrôle
continu et je savais déjà si je l'avais
ou non très rapidement on a pas eu
d'épreuve je suis jeunesse vous avez des
souvenirs c'est toujours très très
marquant le bac moi je vais me souvenir
de ma dernière épreuve de philo qui a
duré trois heures trois quarts avec une
prof qui voulait absolument pas me
la formule a évolué cette année
effectivement c'était une formule aussi
nouvelle de ce baccalauréat 2023 alors
dans l'actualité également Régine ce
matin un incendie c'est déclaré sur le
site de l'hôtel aérotel à
Saint-Cyr-l'École
vers 10h les pompiers ont déployé trois
véhicules deux hélicoptères ont
également été appelés en renfort ainsi
que quatre ambulances et le SAMU alors
on ignore pour l'instant les causes de
ce sinistre l'hôtel qui accueillait des
mineurs isolés annonce que deux
adolescents âgés de 14 à 17 ans sont
entre la vie et la mort cette fois-ci
dans la ville de Guern qui a ravagé
plusieurs hectares de récoltes hier dans
l'après-midi alors dans un champ
d'avoine plus de 22 hectares de récoltes
ont été réduits en cendres puis d'une
cinquantaine de pompiers ont été
mobilisés une enquête a été ouverte par
la gendarmerie pour déterminer les
causes de cette incendie avec une
actualité plus douce dans la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux justement le
weekend dernier c'était la fête de la
ville et avec un thème cette année en
route pour les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 c'était à la Ferme
du Manet les inimontains étaient invités
à se plonger dans l'ambiance des Jeux
Olympiques ils ont pu s'initier à
différents sports encadrés par des
associations telles que du handball
fauteuil de liquidation ou encore du tir
à l'arc qu'on écoute José Cachin
l'adjoint emmerde délégué à la culture
et à l'événementiel au micro de tv78 il
est important me semble-t-il en tout cas
de de commencer à à sensibiliser les
gens et en quelque sorte à faire monter
la mayonnaise
en attendant l'arrivée de de ces JP
merci Régine pour ces informations et si
vous aussi comme d'habitude près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
[Musique]
que en un quart d'heure des années de
travail d'efforts au travers de la
destruction d'un bâtiment public d'un
véhicule communal d'un poste de police
municipale on voit que des années de
travail d'investissement et de
mobilisation et le service qui rendu à
nos habitants par ces équipements par
temps fumé et ça c'est assez
insupportable et c'était extrêmement
traumatisant et je pense que c'est bien
que au plus haut niveau de l'État on
prenne conscience que les mers sont
proches de leurs habitants et qu'ils
sont qu'ils sont les le premier maillon
de la de la grande chaîne de
fonctionnement du service public et de
l'État il y a un sentiment d'abandon de
la part des villes de l'État à l'irrabel
le maire de Trappes disait ce matin chez
nos confrères de France Info il est
assez offensif il parlait d'un président
arrogant qui ne s'intéresse aux banlieue
que quand ça brûle finalement il y a un
sentiment d'abandon qui est ressenti
aussi dans votre ville je crois que
c'est pas très juste de parler de
sentiment d'abandon il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont faites après il faudrait
se poser la question de savoir qui fait
quoi comment pourquoi et de quelle
manière je pense qu'il y a eu énormément
de de choses qui ont été faites et ont
beaucoup de chansons faites pour les
quartiers alors l'abondance c'est un
sentiment c'est pas forcément toujours
une réalité donc c'est comme
l'insécurité on peut avoir on peut avoir
un sentiment d'insécurité sans pour
autant qu'il y ait une insécurité non je
crois que effectivement on demandera
toujours plus parce que on a toujours le
souci de faire mieux pour nos habitants
de là parler d'abandon je sais pas si le
terme est le plus approprié nous lisez
les les maires les élus en général sont
en première ligne il y a eu quand même
un soutien à leur soutien de la part des
habitants d'anonymes de toute la France
il y a eu de nombreux rassemblements
hier devant les maires ça a été le cas
Montigny-le-Bretonneux aussi beaucoup de
soutien de la part des habitants
absolument on a eu on a eu une très très
belle rencontre hier à midi avec les
habitants de de Montigny
lemercaire mère de Montigny a fait un
très très beau discours qui a été
longuement applaudit on a senti des des
des des des habitants proches de de
leurs élus qui étaient présents en
nombre et on a eu on a on a eu beaucoup
de paroles réconfortantes et
reconnaissante pour le travail qui était
fait et puis pour ce qu'il allait
falloir maintenant des encouragements et
un soutien très très large et ça fait
quelques images à mort pas et à
Guyancourt notamment sur sur ces
rassemblements également à Élancourt
vous le voyez actuellement à l'image
alors l'annonce à retenir du président
de la République c'est qu'il y aura la
présentation très rapidement d'une loi
d'urgence pour reconstruire beaucoup
plus vite dans les villes qui ont été
touchées par des destructions ça va dans
le bon sens selon vous il fallait aller
peut-être un peu plus loin pour le
président de la République qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette annonce bah je
pense que c'est important de dire qu'on
va reconstruire parce qu'il y a un
traumatisme de de de de qui est présent
et que on essaye de gommer les les
images dans nos villes on essaie de dans
la mesure du possible de de réparer le
plus vite possible parce qu'il y a un
impact très négatif hier on a fait
enlever une voiture qui était calcinée
devant une école les enfants se
plaignaient disaient qu'ils avaient peur
d'aller à l'école parce qu'il voyait
cette cette voiture devant leur école
donc on l'a fait enlever en urgence bien
sûr qu'il faut enlever les stigmates
bien sûr qu'il faut essayer de
reconstruire c'est le rôle de de des
élus et c'est bien que le chef de l'État
s'engage auprès des collectivités
locales dans
particulier qui devait partir avec ces
bus on trouvera des solutions de
remplacement évidemment on ne laissera
pas nos enfants sans partir en vacances
mais avouez quand même que le symbole
est un peu douloureux dans les
destruction on observait aussi des
destructions de commerce le magasin
action à Montigny-le-Bretonneux aussi
les commerçants de la place Claudel à
Montigny qui ont été victime de pillage
les commerçants aussi ont été largement
touchés les commerçants étaient
largement touchés le premier soir
mercredi c'est centré sur l'angle sur la
place Étienne Marcel avec le commerce
action donc qui est quand même un peu
emblématique du centre-ville il y a eu
aussi le petit chien qui était juste à
côté qui a eu ces vitrines brisées des
voitures qui ont brûlées dans le secteur
plusieurs voitures bon et le lendemain
donc dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi ça
a été la place Claudel qui a été le
théâtre de de d'attaque et on a pu
suivre ces attaques soit en direct
passer avec le maire on a circulé dans
la ville pendant que ce produisait ces
événements le lendemain les a suivis au
moyen de caméra et
c'est terrible parce que parce qu'on
voit sous nos yeux ce qui se passe on
voit des des gamins ce sont des pour
certains ce sont des gamins qui ont 13
14 ans et là effectivement on peut se
demander qu'est-ce qu'ils font là deux
heures trois heures du matin dans les
rues moi je ne sais pas j'ai eu des
enfants je garantis que mes enfants à
l'âge de 13 ans ils étaient pas dans la
rue après 22h donc on peut se poser la
question aussi de la responsabilité il y
a on se stigmatise le rôle de l'État en
stigmatise tout ça mais peut-être qu'il
faut revenir au fondamentaux peut-être
aussi que dans les familles il y a une
attention plus importante qui devrait
être portée à ce que font les enfants et
et c'est un devoir je veux dire la
citoyenneté ça commence aussi et d'abord
dans la famille et le rôle des parents
est tout à fait fondamental et je crois
que c'est bien de le rappeler les
commerçants en colère on peut bien le
comprendre on a croisé justement le
gérant de ce commerce d'imprimerie place
Claudel qui souhaitait poser une
question à la municipalité je vous
propose de l'écouter je suis en colère
et je voudrais que Monsieur le Maire
vous puissiez me répondre
que s'est-il passé entre le jeudi soir
et le dimanche et même ce soir et enfin
hier soir dimanche soir pour que des
commerces soient encore vandalisés à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux malgré le
discours entre guillemets ou la
politique ultra sécurité caméra vidéo
polysarmée casque ganté voilà moi je
veux savoir également Monsieur le Maire
le nombre de fonctionnaires de police le
nombre de véhicules et les moyens loi la
police et pourquoi ça s'est passé comme
ça vous n'êtes pas le maire Eric Alain
jeunesse mais si vous avez des éléments
de réponse à apporter oui j'ai des
éléments de réponse je te redirais
simplement que que la police nationale a
fait ce qu'elle a pu en coordination
avec la police municipale que les
services de police ne sont pas
dimensionnés pour des émeutes et de son
là pour assurer la sécurité au quotidien
des habitants que lorsque vous avez des
hordes avec quatre groupes de 40
personnes qui débarquent sur un quartier
et bien avec 5 ou 6 véhicules de police
bah vous avez deux solutions soit vous
allez au carton et vous vous faites
démolir parce qu'il y a pas d'autres
mots ou alors vous essayez de gérer au
peu la situation en essayant de contenir
et évidemment la sécurité des commerces
est un souci
essentiel mais encore une fois on est on
était dans quelques je comprends la
colère de ce monsieur mais on était dans
une situation totalement exceptionnelle
je veux dire pour l'avoir vécu en direct
je vous garantis que quand vous ne
passez le premier soir avec le véhicule
de Sigler police mais les Les
Invincibles que nous avons subi on a dû
s'en aller parce que on était plus en
phase d'individus on était plus en phase
d'être humain on était en face d'une
meute qui était enragée et je vous
garantis que si par malheur on avait dû
être stoppé je ne donne pas cher de nos
vies donc oui on peut être en colère oui
on peut remettre en cause et c'est il
est de Menton de mettre en cause les
municipalités les mères on est apporté
d'engueulade donc on est responsable de
tout là en l'occurrence malheureusement
on n'a pas été les seuls à être impactés
on a vu ce qui s'est passé sur plan
national je dirais que évidemment
lorsque on a son commerce qui est
dégradé on ressent une frustration une
douleur une révolte mais la mise en
cause de il faut mettre en cause les
bonnes personnes et là en l'occurrence
c'est pas la municipalité qui est en
cause on n'a pas assez prérogatives et
on n'a pas bien de suffisamment les
effectifs pour contenir 160 personnes
sur sur une place ça c'était pas
possible une dernière question pour
l'après je sais pas si on y réfléchit
déjà à montigny-le-breteuse qui s'est
passé dans la commune est-ce que ça peut
nourrir un futur travail municipal
de toute façon on va réfléchir
évidemment chaque fois qu'une qu'une
catastrophe arrive et je crois que là on
peut parler de catastrophe alors
catastrophe pas seulement économique
mais team catastrophe dans le lien
social parce que c'est ça c'est tout ce
lien qu'on tisse au quotidien avec les
habitants ses habitants des quartiers on
a nos éducateurs de rue eux aussi ils
sont peut-être un petit peu désespérés
parce que tous ces enfants qui sont pris
en charge j'espère que la majorité était
chez eux mais oui il y a quand même
aussi une des failles et personne n'est
parfait on va travailler on va
reconstruire on est on sera toujours
proche de nos habitants parce que c'est
notre devoir et puis on essaiera de de
voir dans quelle mesure on peut prévenir
les choses en sachant que la sécurité à
100% ça n'existe pas et que ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas non plus l'objectif on ne
peut pas rentrer dans le tout
sécuritaire mais de toute façon on fera
toujours plus est-ce que disait hier le
maire dans le discours c'est que il y a
quand même une certaine frustration dans
une ville qui fait autant pour ses
habitants de voir que derrière ben voilà
on se retrouve lors des meute à avoir
autant de autant de dégradations et
d'exactions pour autant on travaille
pour la majorité la majorité elle était
présente hier matin sur le parvis elle a
applaudit
elle applaudit le discours républicain
du maire elle a chanté la Marseillaise
et c'est pour cela d'abord qu'on
travaille et bien sûr pour les autres
pour essayer de les ramener justement
dans le giron de de la ville et plus
largement dans le giron de la nation
merci
Erica lingenet je rappelle que vous êtes
mère adjoint de Montigny Bretonneux
délégué à la citoyenneté à la sécurité
on devra présent dans le 7 8 une page
culture
[Musique]
et direction Élancourt pour débuter la
semaine dernière l'école 3e l'Institut
international de l'image et du son et
l'oncle organisé des porteuses ouvertes
les étudiants notamment de la filière
jeux vidéo ont pu présenter leurs œuvres
des jeux vidéo sur lesquels ils ont
travaillé pendant près d'un an reportage
de Michael elmidoro et de Julien Leroy
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'école 3e
Bazet Élancourt la filière à cinéma
d'animation et jeux vidéo va présenter
ses projets à tes professionnels
[Musique]
une journée spéciale pour la santé
d'étudiants de la filière présente ce
jour-là de 5e année à travailler sur le
jeu shift pendant 10 mois avec ses
camarades à Élancourt un jeu d'énigme de
parcours en 3D dans un univers de
science-fiction
où les gens sont dû tester nos jeux mais
c'est juste tout public là c'est
vraiment les professionnels de
l'industrie qui viennent et qui viennent
juger est-ce que nos jeux sont bons me
faire des retours qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait améliorer qu'est-ce qui est
déjà bien et du coup on est très content
que ça se passe parce que nous bien sûr
en fin d'études on recherche aussi des
stages on recherche à se
professionnaliser et donc c'est avec des
retours de gens professionnels de
l'industrie qu'on va pouvoir se
professionnaliser et rentrer dans
l'industrie et développer enfin comment
ça notre carrière une porte ouverte qui
a attiré plusieurs entreprises ce jeudi
29 juin ils ont passé la journée avec
les étudiants inscrits de la première
année de Bachelor à la cinquième année
peut-être que tu aurais pu faire un lien
entre le sentiment que tu voulais
faire ressentir dans chacune des pièces
et une un panel de couleur et une
direction de lumière en plus de donner
des conseils sur les différents projets
les gros studios de jeux vidéo sont
venus dénicher les nouveaux talents avec
quelque part oui on fait notre marché on
vient aussi repérer les tendances on
vient aussi repérer
la qualité de formation et
potentiellement la faire améliorer pour
la suite et c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
collaboration entre les écoles et
Ubisoft l'occasion de laisser son CV
pour les étudiants certains jeux vidéo
sont déjà en discussion avec des
professionnels pour une
commercialisation une vraie réussite
pour l'école qui a relancé cette filière
depuis un an pour certains c'est la
première fois où il faisait un jeu vidéo
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez d'assez
exceptionnel parce que le résultat est
là quoi les professionnels nous le
disent reviennent vers nous ils disent
bah oui c'est réussi et en plus il faut
pas oublier que aujourd'hui à troisièces
on n'a pas encore de formation de
programmeur bon j'ai craqué je vais
tester un jeu créé ici dans les studios
3IS le jeu Jim qui a été créé par les
étudiants de 5e année c'est parti au
total une dizaine de jantes été créés
ici pendant l'année
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
non j'ai pas joué en poser la question
emplettes ou alors il n'y a pas que le
jeu vidéo d'ailleurs qui était à
l'honneur la filière aussi animation à
3IS avec sa journée dédiée c'était le 27
juin dernier on en parle avec vous
Sylvain bonnet vous êtes le responsable
pédagogique de la filière et également
un étudiant de deuxième année
qui est donc étudiant en cinéma
d'animation 2D déjà peut-être quelques
mots de présentation sur la filière
animation combien d'étudiants
aujourd'hui la composent alors on a peu
près 90 étudiants dans la dans la
filière Cimade d'animation après
l'équivalent aussi en jeu vidéo parce
qu'en fait on tisse un lien de toute
manière avec avec eux il y avait
beaucoup de formations de de métier
commun on va dire avec le jeu vidéo donc
ce qui fait l'arrivée 130 environ 134
étudiants pour cette année et combien de
formations typiquement vraiment sur la
filière animation alors l'animation on
est à la formation Bachelor on commence
par trois années effectivement pour se
former au dessin à toutes les
compétences on va dire de base pour pour
vraiment avoir les équipes pour
commencer à produire des premiers courts
métrages et ensuite on a la formation
master sur deux ans qui a la continuité
du Bachelor et qui permet cette fois-ci
après les premiers acquis les bases
consolidées en troisième année de la fin
du Bachelor et bien en master on va
devenir un peu plus expert on va dire
dans des métiers plus spécifiques encore
plus dans l'animation pour et produire
un projet de fin d'année 5e année
beaucoup plus conséquent en équipe un
court-métrage d'environ 4 à 5 minutes
donc vous Ilyes vous êtes en deuxième
année pour le moment donc dans la
filière Bachelor finalement c'est pour
avoir le Bachelor à la fin de ces trois
ans c'est bien ça alors cinéma 2D
pourquoi ce choix qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît dans dans le cinéma d'animation
moi ce qui me plaît surtout c'est tout
ce qui est raconté des histoires à
travers le médium qui est l'animation le
dessin c'est une passion tout autant que
racontait des histoires et que ça à
écrire et vraiment ça c'est la passion
parfaite qui cumule les deux je dirais
c'est pour ça et qu'est-ce qui est au
menu de votre formation qu'est-ce que
vous avez pu apprendre par exemple cette
année on a pu apprendre toutes les bases
un peu du dessin parce que ça reste
essentiel même si on raconte des
histoires il faut pour le mieux les
raconter il faut avoir des bonnes bases
en dessin donc c'est anatomie
perspective les couleurs
la mise en scène toutes les bases du
dessin possible et après on a aussi
quelques cours de cinéma avec un
cinéphile qui a écrit à plusieurs livres
etc très intéressant voilà c'est des
études de mise en scène des
présentations de films etc voir un peu
ce qui se cache derrière les histoires
ce n'est pas juste des dessins animés
des fois il y a des auteurs ils ont
toujours une intention derrière voilà et
je disais vous avez pu travailler tout à
l'heure on le disait tout à l'heure sur
un projet cette année qui a été présenté
lors des trois is days effectivement moi
j'étais sur un projet individuel
petit défi de ma part parce que c'est
pas forcément évident
dans la rue et un boulanger la trappe en
train de voler et au final le boulanger
rattrape l'enfant et la morale c'est un
peu le boulanger voilà au début il
voulait un peu tabasser l'enfant vous
repasse sa colère et final il se rend
compte que voilà c'est un enfant à la
rue qui est des autres enfants qui
étaient dans les rues en disciplant de
la nourriture et au final le boulanger
décide de l'emboucher avec lui dans son
boulanger on disait tout à l'heure
l'objectif de des trois USD c'était de
valoriser
ces exemples de de projets qu'on peut
mener les étudiants cette année tout à
fait c'était vraiment de montrer encore
une fois cette année que l'école a
répondu présente on a eu je crois après
presque 30 projets en animation dans
toutes les dans toutes les classes
confondues on a eu des séries on a eu
des courts métrages on a eu énormément
de travaux d'étudiants également donc
sur l'aspect de la 2D comme l'aspect de
la 3D avec des films plus ou moins
engagés victime plutôt à la teneur à
être des films d'auteur des drames des
comédies le truc le cru était vraiment
bon et puis on a réussi à mener à bien
des projets très techniques et des
projets totalement en 3D on a mis en
place à l'école comment est-ce qu'on
fait dans les studios ce qu'on appelle
une grandeur forme c'est que on a pu
calculer avec des heures et des heures
des centaines d'heures des productions
avec une qualité que les professionnels
voilà ont eu une grande satisfaction en
tout cas de visionner alors la France
est reconnue dans le monde entier pour
la filière animation troisième pays le
plus influent au monde dans l'industrie
de l'animation qui est meilleur que nous
par la France alors en fait c'est c'est
terrible c'est vraiment une guerre de
chiffres alors qu'en fait en réalité moi
j'ai envie de dire on est quand même
quasiment les premiers sur le point de
vue j'irai là la culture qu'on apporte
on va dire la créativité qu'on apporte
dans le monde on est troisième en fait à
l'heure actuelle derrière les Japonais
les Américains mais ce qui se passe on a
des pros des grandes productions des
gros blocs j'ai envie de dire comme par
exemple
aussi studio et Nîmes par exemple ou
c'est en fait des productions
américaines mais en réalité en fait
c'est ce sont les Français les Français
qui travaillent dessus qui travaillent
dessus voilà donc les étrangers ont un
regard sur nous vraiment très positif on
est très très recherché puisque à leurs
yeux on apporte ce petit quelque chose
en plus c'est de culture peut-être en
plus et ce qu'on apporte en tout cas ici
à Troyes ou la même ce que ce qu'elle
dit la même ce qu'on apporte en dessin
en technique de 3D de 2D qui savent tous
travailler en studio au delà ça on leur
apporte effectivement une certaine
vision une volonté d'apporter un
engagement finalement une portée je
dirais à changer un petit peu le monde
quelque part grâce à ce qu'il fabrique
donc voilà ça vous fait rêver il y a ce
qu'on voyait ce qui est produit
actuellement par le cinéma d'animation
français qui est souvent privé à
l'international aussi c'est vrai que moi
j'étais pas forcément très au courant
etc de que la France était très
populaire etc mais au final quand j'ai
découvert j'étais très surpris
effectivement ça fait rêver parce que
c'est en pleine expansion et ça ne
réserve que le mieux pour l'avenir de
tous les étudiants ils sont actuellement
en animation au niveau européen premier
rang pour la France 40% de la production
européenne vient de l'Hexagone il y a
165 studios qui sont installés en France
on a envie de se dire que c'est quand
même un secteur qui qui recrute on
l'espère sinon c'est un secteur qui
recrute mais en plus en pleine expansion
avec effectivement toujours
ce regard de nouveautés avec la
technologie qui va avec effectivement on
entend beaucoup parler à l'intelligence
artificielle mais aussi une évolution
technologique qui se fait en parallèle
et la France en tout cas c'est toujours
bien répondre effectivement à ces
nouvelles technologies et puis et bien
forcément derrière les écoles en école
3S on est on est on encadre
effectivement nous étions avec des
professionnels avant tout qui ces
derniers sont au courant effectivement
des des dernières nouveautés
technologiques et notre but c'est à
chaque fois chaque année se remettre en
question se remettre toujours à niveau
et apporter un contenu pédagogique qui
soit toujours à hauteur des technologies
ça garant un emploi après est-ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de d'anciens étudiants qui
sont aujourd'hui dans le dans les
studios de production tout à fait on en
a on en a beaucoup par exemple qui
partent par exemple
dans pas mal du Sud d'animation en
France mais aussi à l'étranger
pour en tout cas et mener à bien
effectivement ce parcours il faut avant
tout des étudiants qui travaillent et
donc on sélectionne effectivement chaque
année nous étudiants donc il faut
l'école mais aussi il faut travailler il
faut apporter sa graine on va dire il
faut être acteur de sa formation quelque
part et donc pour tous ceux qui
effectivement jouent ce jeu aucun souci
pour pour entrer dans le monde du
travail question pratique comment on
intègre 3IS on a parlé tout à l'heure
avec le bac en fait il faut être donc
bachelier il faut avoir effectivement
des résultats quand même satisfaisants
on va dire aussi dans ce qu'on appelle
les soft skills c'est qu'on oublie
souvent mais il y a pas que les
compétences par les notes mais également
le comportement l'assivité sentir que si
on a en face de nous quelqu'un de
créatif qui est en quelque part envie de
changer le monde et qui a surtout envie
de se donner à fond dans dans les études
qui veut poursuivre et et puis et puis
derrière on va leur demander un petit
book quand j'ai petit book c'est à dire
qu'on va pas la formation est là quand
même pour apporter les niveaux on va
leur demander tout un tas de dessins
d'observations surtout montrer des
choses du quotidien de ce qu'ils font ça
peut être également des supports visuels
des vidéos des images digitales il y a
là-dessus aucun souci on trouve toutes
les informations sur le site de 3e le
coût d'une année le coût d'une année
c'est environ à peu près 8000 à partir
de 1000 euros l'année on va dire voilà
pour pour chaque année le mot de la fin
avec vous Ilyes vous rêvez de faire quoi
après qu'est-ce qu'elles sont vos
projets au début de l'année j'aurais pas
pu répondre à votre question mais au fur
et à mesure j'ai trouvé grâce à la
formation et je pense je me dirais vers
sorry border donc c'est dans la
pré-production etc c'est une phase
importante qui est vraiment reliée au
fait de raconter des histoires bonne
continuation à vous merci à tous les
deux d'être venu parler de cette filière
animation à troisièces d'autres filières
aussi dans cette école vous retrouvez
bien sûr toutes les informations sur le
site Internet de trois is jusqu'au 27
août 2023 de cette année bien sûr se
tient la septième édition estivale des
jardins ouverts en Île-de-France
l'objectif de l'événement c'est de
découvrir le patrimoine naturel et
culturel de la région parmi les jardins
proposés le Potager du Roi bien sûr
installé à Versailles ou artiste et
visiteur était au rendez-vous pour ce
weekend de lancement Gabriel Gontier
Mélanie Poitiers quand le patrimoine se
mêle à l'art le temps d'un week-end le
Potager du Roi de Versailles s'est
transformé en atelier à ciel ouvert un
moyen de découvrir le patrimoine
culturel et naturel de la région donc
là-haut la petite
réserve d'encre
à l'occasion de la septième édition
estivale des jardins ouverts le célèbre
jardin versaillé a ouvert ses portes aux
artistes dont l'intérêt est double c'est
de faire découvrir le jardin d'une autre
manière effectivement
et d'interroger aussi pour pour les
visiteurs ce dialogue alors ici entre
l'art et le jardin sculpteur ou encore
art
iste ont répondu à l'appel pour présent
leurs oeuvres dans un cadre exceptionnel
auquel il faut s'adapter il a eu la
chance de rencontrer le chef jardinier
ici on lui a posé pas mal de questions
sur ces alignements c'est ça qui nous a
inspiré d'essayer de créer une forme qui
jaillissent finalement de cette
alignement parfait magnifique et donc on
a créé cette œuvre qui est une force
d'eau de la nature du vivant une
explosion en fait de bissonnante une
cohérence entre l'art et la nature que
les artistes exploitent et qui les
inspirent je propose aux participants de
réaliser des des plaques collectives
chacun vient graver à son tour dans une
plaque de bois un motif un élément de
branchage qui va grandir au fur et à
mesure et l'ouverture de ces jardins
estivaux à attirer les curieux comme ce
père et sa fille venue un peu par hasard
on laisse libre cours à son imagination
ce qui est quand même très intéressant
on peut travailler la matière les
couleurs on découvre des nouvelles
techniques et puis on travaille en
famille ça permet à tout le monde qu'on
soit adulte sur mon avis les enfants de
réaliser quelque chose de la fois
créatif et
facile et si vous aussi vous souhaitez
vous essayez à des ateliers artistiques
tout en profitant de la beauté du
patrimoine local vous avez jusqu'au 27
août pour profiter des jardins ouverts
dans le département on reste à
Versailles Gabriel Gontier était allé à
la rencontre de Léo questem à l'occasion
de la sortie de son dernier livre Le
Manoir de kerbrooke l'auteur professeur
et scénariste atteint de cécité revient
sur son ouvrage et sa carrière dans un
nouveau numéro de vyb bonjour à toutes
bonjour à tous on se retrouve au foyer
royal du château de Versailles pour un
nouveau numéro de VIP en compagnie de
Léo Castel bonjour Léo merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation alors vous
êtes professeur agrégé d'allemand
auteurs scénariste vous vivez à
Versailles et si on vous reçoit
aujourd'hui c'est parce que vous avez
récemment paru aux éditions Baudelaire
votre dernier livre Le Manoir de
kerbroke alors l'intrigue se passe dans
un manoir coton à l'apparence secrète
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière ce lieu
Léo alors ça se passe effectivement en
Bretagne parce que kerbrooke plus breton
que ça tumeur bon et à Versailles aussi
et ceux qui se cache dans ce manoir ce
sont des secrets de famille un peu lourd
et ce sont des secrets qui auront des
conséquences terribles sur la vie de
cette famille bien versaillaise de cette
noblesse bretonne qui vient Versailles
dans ce propos vous parlez d'une femme
battue qui cherche à s'émanciper est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un petit
peu et pourquoi cette thématique de la
violence aussi
c'est une question qui qui est difficile
j'ai essayé de résumer en fait l'héroïne
s'appelle Héloïse bon elle dépend de son
mari parce qu'elle travaille pas donc
c'est lui qui ramène l'argent au foyer
le schéma d'une société patriarcale
finalement c'est ça c'est tout à fait ça
et puis lui il peut vivre sa vie
puisqu'il a plusieurs
usines et quand il n'est pas là il mène
la vie qu'il veut même elle vie privée
qu'elle regarde et elle elle est là à
attendre son mari
à avoir les idées de son mari parce
qu'elle est presque obligée d'avoir les
idées de son mari et puis petit à petit
des choses se dégradent enfin petit à
petit c'est pas vrai parce que la
violence en général dans un couple
s'installe très vite bon et puis il y a
de la violence le mari est violent
dans tous les milieux ça arrive et puis
moi je dirais qu'une femme très
amoureuse au début du mariage ne doit
jamais laisser s'installer ne serait-ce
qu'une petite gifle donc ce couple se
dégrade petit à petit quand elle prend
conscience
de sa propre existence à elle elle va
retrouver sa liberté finalement elle va
retrouver sa liberté à quel prix parce
qu'une séparation ce n'est jamais anodin
et puis elle a deux de gamins des
adolescents enfin c'est pas des gamins
oh des grands gamins
et on sait que parfois les adolescents
ça peut être
un tout petit peu pénible d'ailleurs un
jour elle est tellement excédé qu'elle
va voir son confident qui se prénomme
Éloi pour lui dire à Éloi j'ai besoin
d'une coupe de champagne
mais mes ados me fatigue je vais creuser
un trou dans mon jardin et je vais les y
enterrer et c'est comme ça que le début
tu le livre d'ailleurs voilà exactement
pour revenir sur les enfants justement
parce qu'on a parlé de cette thématique
de la violence mais il y a une autre
thématique qui est importante dans votre
livre c'est celui de l'homosexualité qui
concerne un des enfants et la difficulté
pour certains parents de l'accepter
est-ce que vous vouliez ouvrir justement
à la réflexion avec cette thématique oui
oui à tout prix et surtout à Versailles
enfin quand je dis surtout à Versailles
je vis à Versailles mais enfin vous le
savez aussi à Versailles il y a eu
beaucoup de personnes pour être contre
le mariage pour tous il y a eu à
l'époque aussi beaucoup de personnes
pour être contre le PACS enfin c'est une
société très traditionnaliste bon
j'imagine d'ailleurs que dans toutes ces
personnes qui ont manifesté contre le
mariage pour tous ils ont dû avoir des
enfants qui un jour on fait leur coming
out mais ça j'ai pas de preuve c'est un
vrai sujet de société
mais oui et pour moi
finalement c'est le garçon qui annonce
son homosexualité et dans l'image
paternelle celui qui a des usines celui
qui voudrait que son fils reprenne les
usines et puis qu'il fasse comme à
Versailles des prépas pour devenir ingés
à Versailles on devient ingénieur voilà
et on fait Polytechnique ou je sais pas
moi
le métier des grandes écoles voilà alors
en plus lui veut devenir pâtissier et en
plus il avoue son homosexualité le père
il faudrait lui mettre une civière pour
qu'il puisse tout de suite tomber sans
se faire mal merci Léo questem de nous
avoir accordé cet entretien et à bientôt
pour un nouveau numéro de VIP
et cette émission vyb est à retrouver en
intégralité sur notre site Internet et
notre chaîne Youtube est l'anime
justement avec brio l'émission very
yvelinoise personne sur TV 78 c'est
Véronique qui Turbide bonsoir Véronique
bonsoir
très bien et on vous retrouve comme
chaque mardi pour vos insolites c'est
tout de suite
alors je sais pas si c'est l'approche
des vacances mais ce soir vous allez
nous donner l'envie de voyager avec
toujours un pied dans les Yvelines ça
c'est ça c'est premier et vous n'en nous
emmener d'abord à la rencontre d'un
couple d'Yves Linois
donc un pied dans les Yvelines oui parce
qu'ils sont de la Vallée de Chevreuse
sont Valérie et Bertrand degruzon qui
sont en fait des amoureux de la Grèce et
qui proposent des voyages un peu hors
normes à moto avec un parcours un
circuit et des adresses enfin je vais
vous expliquer ça donc eux c'est
l'historique de ce cette histoire de
cette aventure c'est qu'il reste ça
ressemble trois passions déjà la passion
de la moto pour Bertrand Valérie qui
était passagère a fini par elle-même
attraper le virus et passer sans permis
la passion de la Grèce où il passe leurs
vacances depuis plus de 10 ans qu'ils
connaissent comme leurs poches et puis
leur passion commune se couple s'aiment
et heureux de faire quelque chose
ensemble qui les amuse donc à force
d'aller en Grèce et de connaître plein
de choses leurs amis leur demander
toujours des adresses des bons plans etc
ils sont dit mais pourquoi pas en faire
carrément une activité en plus de leur
job actuel donc qui sont associés tous
les deux et ils sont maintenant
voyageistes imaginez-vous mais alors
leur propositions sont un peu
particulière c'est à dire que ce qu'il
existe déjà c'est soit des voyages à
moto de proximité ou alors des voyages à
moto à l'autre bout du monde souvent sur
des pistes à nos béquistes enfin des
endroits très très loin eux c'est un peu
un compromis entre les deux c'est à dire
que vous arrivez à Athènes vous louez
ils sont avec vous il y a une formule
tout compris c'est un groupe vous êtes 6
à 8 motos et il vous guide du début à la
fin vous louez donc là il voulut la moto
pardon j'ai du mal et c'est une BMW
c'est toujours pourquoi parce que
sécurité confort c'est comme ça il y a
quand même de la route faut savoir que
la graisse 80% de relief donc ça monte
ça descend c'est pas il y a pas de pic
de vitesse on respecte la nature on en
profite on est au plus près de la nature
c'est magnifique voilà mère montagne on
peut s'arrêter c'est souple ils
connaissent des bons petits restos enfin
il vous donne les clés pour profiter de
l'authenticité du pays hors des sentiers
battus ces voyages là en groupe c'est
hors saison c'est avant l'été et après
l'été là où la Grèce est la moins
envahit par les touristes après il y a
une formule où il ne vous accompagne pas
vous pouvez être à deux tout seul ou
avec des copains et là vous avez le
parcours les guides et tout ça mais ils
sont pas avec vous et une autre conseil
ah ben complètement vous avez vraiment
les clés pour souvent quand on voit des
choses très authentiques des petits
restos ça on n'ose pas trop parce qu'on
sait pas comment se comporter là où vous
êtes sûr d'être bien accueilli ils
connaissent les gens et les Grecs vous
attendent avec un grand bonheur et ou
après il y a encore une formule
vous ne faites que louer la moto et
parce que c'est pas évident et après et
un jour bientôt il y aura une autre
encore formule où vous partirez de
France avec votre propre moto et vous
mettrez eux c'est ce qui depuis 5 ans il
se donne 10 jours pour atteindre la
Grèce en passant par l'ouzbé les Balkans
enfin bref véritable aventure qui vont
bientôt nous faire partager en Suisse de
celle-là voilà alors toujours en lien
avec la graisse une versaillesse qui a
créé un objet qui a retenu votre
attention avec complètement parce que
c'est bien utile et en plus c'est joli
elle s'appelle Séverine Saki elle aussi
passe ses vacances en Grèce dans sa
famille depuis très longtemps et elle
remarque que elle est souvent importunée
par les guêpes quand on déjeune dehors
ou qu'on dîne dehors bref ça fait partie
du truc donc elle a essayé des méthodes
qui n'ont pas très très bien marché le
marc de café brûlé ça sent pas très bon
on est enfumé là la raquette électrique
c'est un peu moche la bouteille de sirop
plein de cadavre de guêpes ça donne
envie de vomir aussi ces techniques
c'est vrai que ça marche pas vous allez
en connaître une nouvelle voilà et un
jour par hasard dans un hôtel en Grèce
elle a vu une petite cabane à guêpes
justement c'est que ce truc et en fait
j'ai dit mais je vais faire la même
chose peut-être un peu plus sophistiqué
donc avec un menuisier local elle a
étudié le problème elle a trouvé un
système donc c'est c'est un objet qui
est très joli qui est design dans lequel
vous mettez de la protéine parce que la
guêpe pour nourrir ses larves elle veut
des protéines et comme ça vous êtes sûr
de pas attirer les abeilles aussi parce
que c'est grâce à cet appât là qu'on
attrape pas les abeilles parce que faut
quand même faire attention vous avez
aussi donc la guêpe avec ses petites
pattes elles montent la petite marge
elle rentre dans le petit tube et boum
elle trouve son repas elle est ravie par
contre elle veut pas repartir toute
seule et vous vous êtes tranquille vous
déjeunez en paix parce que comme je dis
bien souvent il y a pas que Stéphane
Eicher qui a envie de déjeuner en fait
alors voilà et donc elle a trouvé donc
le concept là ça marche très bien il y a
deux restaurants à Versailles qui ont
cette piège à guêpe qu'elle appelle le
guet-apens et
la Guinguette et le chat qui prise et
alors il faut savoir aussi que c'est un
objet qui est fait en bois de de je ne
sais plus pas Douglas voilà bois
certifié tout ce qu'il faut fabrication
solidaire parce que cette année ça tu
l'as est très près de Cergy-Pontoise qui
fabrique donc déjà des gens qui sont en
insertion professionnelle voilà il y a
un projet en plus
et donc c'est une fois que vous avez
fini votre déjeuner votre pas vous
pouvez libérer les guêpes elle sortiront
à leur rythme sans violence et la
biodiversité et respectée c'est
inoffensif pour les insectes vous vous
êtes bien tranquille et
tout va bien vous mettez des chansons
dans la tête en tout cas c'est en train
de chanter Stéphane Eicher en régie Véro
et pour terminer je le disais vous
présenter avec brio cette émission
very vinoise personnelle qui met en
lumière les personnalités du département
alors l'un de vos derniers numéros vous
avez vous êtes allés à la rencontre du
jardinier en chef du grand parc de
Versailles du domaine national de
Trianon bien sûr à l'embarathon notre
ami fidèle qui à chaque fois qu'il sort
un livre nous reçoit gentiment donc là
c'est le livre de la rose on était en
son jardin et nous a raconté il nous a
pas le seul livre plein d'anecdotes
d'historique etc et du coup c'est bien
qu'on en parle parce que j'ai oublié de
dire un truc dans ce VIP je vous le dis
à vous si ça vous intéresse le jour où
planterez un rosier dans le trou avant
de planter le rosier mettez une peau de
banane
pourquoi je ne sais pas
aveuglément j'ai entièrement confiance
en ses talents de jardinier donc à
retrouver dès à présent sur TV 78.com
sur notre site internet en intégralité
on a vu quelques-unes des images merci
Véronique on se dit à mardi prochain
est-ce que vous avez un talent caché
petite question
vous en avez tellement bah oui mais non
caché non
incroyable talent ah oui oui je connais
donc ça ça passe sur la chaîne M6 et
cette émission le casting de cette
émission faisait étape le week-end
dernier à plaisir vous en avez parlé
dans l'un de vos derniers numéros des
insolites de Véronique pour un casting
donc dans le centre commercial au
shopping 80 candidats sont venus
présenter leurs talent pour un casting
devant 500 visiteurs avec l'espoir et de
se voir sélectionner Julien Leroy a
tenté sa chance
sous les feux des projecteurs les
aficionados du programme de M6 La France
a un incroyable talent avait rendez-vous
à plaisir ce samedi 1er juillet chant
humour ou magie 9 candidats étaient
venus faire face à un membre du jury
dans le centre ushopping grand plaisir
objectif décrocher sa place sur le petit
écran en avant nos visiteurs les
territoires puisque
exprimer leur talents sur scène
[Musique]
être une personne unique cet auteur
compositrice originaire des Yvelines
était venu présenter son univers gospel
urbain l'espoir d'une belle exposition
médiatique pour cette jeune artiste de
21 ans il y a toujours un petit stress
enfin un grand stress d'ailleurs quand
il y a autant de personnes et quand on
voit les enjeux mais j'ai vraiment
apprécié l'idéal ce serait effectivement
de gagner après les cent mille euros je
les vois pas comme un gain je les vois
vraiment comme un investissement futur
on a profité de l'occasion qu'un
incroyable talent le casting soit là
pour venir regarder il y avait du bon
niveau dans les champs sur cette journée
deux candidats ont été sélectionnés pour
passer le prochain casting avec la
production du programme un nouveau
rendez-vous avant d'espérer passer à la
télévision
bientôt la fin du 7 8 juste avant de
vous laisser dernier coup d'oeil aux
prévisions météo de demain
une journée de mercredi similaire à
celle d'aujourd'hui avec des éclaircies
prévus dans la matinée de mercredi des
températures plus fraîches également
comptées 15 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 13
degrés à Rambouillet et 14 degrés dans
les secteurs de Versailles et Houdan
dans l'après-midi quelques gouttes de
pluie sont attendus fera 20 degrés sur
l'ensemble du territoire Yvelines noires
et voilà c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité demain vous avez
rendez-vous pour une nouvelle édition
avec Mathilde Franco belle soirée sur TV
[Musique]